si les poches des messieurs jean
petit village
on a coeur de l'exode l'inventeur du
hard rock jim toth
40 millions de disques vendus jimmy
pêche l'inventeur du hard rock bonsoir
merci d'avoir choisi tout mais en parle
alors le 27 mai prochain jimmy pey'j
atlantique va lancer un triple cd un
double dvd de led zep avec des
performances des enregistrements inédits
donc on va faire deux promos d'abord le
triple cd
[Musique]
dès ce mardi
et ensuite le double dvd
[Musique]
jimmy page alors dit me paye si je
voulais résumer votre vie en deux images
je prendrai la première au début des
années 50 le rock'n'roll fait irruption
dans votre vie avec une chanson d'elvis
presley qui s'appelle baby l'ex play
house et c'est une révélation pour vous
la première fois que vous avez entendu
cette chanson ça vous a décidé à vous
mettre à la guitare yahoo l'est en
réalité baby n'espère house était une
face b de disques d'elvis presley et
tout d'un coup je me suis rendu compte
qu'il y avait un mail à la guitare
acoustique
elvis qui qui chantait qui jouait sa
guitare électrique derrière ça faisait
tout un espèce d'orchestre qui m'a
séduit seulement voilà il est devenu
l'un des plus grands guitaristes de rock
du monde et la deuxième image est
toujours lié à elle vise donc vous allez
rester gaz vous rencontrer elvis presley
vous arriver tous les quatre les quatre
led zep un petit peu intimidé devant lui
les gardes du corps sont sont très
nerveux d'ailleurs il ya un petit peu
des problèmes entre les gardes du corps
de led zep et les gardes du corps
d'elvis presley vous trouvez en face de
lui ou sais pas trop quoi lui dire et à
un moment c'est john bonham qui rompt le
silence en disant c'est quoi le hot rod
que tu piloter dans l'amour frénétique
et là d'un seul coup tout le monde se
met à parler
là c'est qu'on pût on a parlé de la
musique les premiers jours puis c'était
c'était un grand départ pour donner
voilà et donc deux fois elvis presley
une fois très jeune et une fois au
sommet de votre gloire alors vous êtes
né jimmy page en 1944 dans le middlesex
le 9 janvier vous êtes capricorne comme
moi alors d'abord vous êtes musicien de
studio vous jouez avec les kinks vous
jouez sur you really got me des kinks
ensuite joué avec joe cocker dans my
friends vous jouez avec donovan vous
jouez avec les ou donc d'abord musicien
de studio et puis à la paix des
yardbirds alors là c'est une grande une
grande période des dans le groupe des
yardbirds avec jeff beck
disait que j'étais un rock'n studio je
jouais avec ses crocs passé prestigieux
y compris d'ailleurs destin française
comme johnny hallyday michel polnareff
également et beaucoup d'autres mais
alors il y avait une star qui était ici
ce soir françoise hardy et j'ai joué sur
un vieux albums mais il ne pouvait pas
le savoir parce que moi j'étais gamin
qui fait la guitare dans le studio et ce
serait peut-être une surprise pour elle
de savoir que je suis devenu ensuite ça
les connaît tous les garçons aiment et
ils s'étaient jimmy p
incroyable
alors les meilleurs buzz après les new
yardbirds qui ont été rebaptisés led
zeppelin par keith moon le batteur des
who parce qu'il avait une phrase il dit
j'ai toujours view legault over like led
zepplin comme un zeppelin en plomb c'est
ça c'était sa phrase dit c'est un peu un
jeu de mots alors le groupe led zeppelin
a été fondée pendant l'été 1968 avec
jimmy page
john badham et john paul jones soit
vraiment énorme
ici c'est pour inventer le marché bute
inventer leurs
[Applaudissements]
dîner
non
en tous les cas merci de tout le bonheur
que nous
merci depuis le groupe s'est arrêté à la
mort de john bonham vous avez des
sentiments de split et le groupe
il ya absolue
parce que le secret de led zeppelin le
secret de son succès ce qui compte c'est
que chaque concert était différente un
jour alors qu il y avait énormément
d'improvisation et à la mort de john n'y
avait pas d'autres plus haut possible
que la dissolution du groupe parce que
même avec les meilleures intentions du
monde des gens venaient nous voir il ya
tel d'un batteur qui appelle remplacer
terry mais en réalité ça n'aurait pas
été honnête parce que le rôle la
contribution de john bonham à 10 ans un
couple qui pense et c'est un batteur
aussi bien que john badham c'est
à dire que je les aide la grosse caisse
comme des castagnettes cp1 c'est un
génie de la batterie d'emballage suit on
entend alors les zep baigné dans une
atmosphère un petit peu cette année est
un petit peu luciférienne on a parlé de
magie noire on a parlé d'un signe nazi
vous étiez branche éparses à l'époque
disons que je m'intéressais au
mysticisme et
vous dire que ce qui m'intéressait
surtout c'était quand même led zeppelin
c'est quand même bon non pas quotidien
et je joue depuis vais-je manger tue les
fils du matin au soir c'est tout ça qui
m'amusait alors vous êtes un grand
admirateur d'un dénommé aleister crowley
grand magicien ou escroc notoire
d'ailleurs les avis sont très partagés
sur lui c'est vrai qu'au mexique c'est
alistair crowley a réussi à faire
disparaître son reflet dans un miroir
c'est au courant de cette histoire
toutes sortes anecdote au sujet de ce
monsieur
mais en fait ce qu'il est en train de
dire c'est que cette époque c'est que
avec la volonté on arrive à tous et
c'est également l'égalité des sexes qui
le qu'il préconisait 2 avec 2 présente
comme un visionnaire absolument en
avance sur son temps et non j'ai vu
c'est givrage mais j'ai également
d'autres auteurs on n'avait pas cueillir
ce n'est pas là la motivation principale
non mais vous avez tout acheter sur lui
que vous avez acheté tous les livres
tous les objets vous pouviez acheter et
vous avez même acheté sa maison à lui
qui est sur le loch ness non
c'est vraiment facile si vous aviez pu
sa maison vous n'auriez également
racheté
était très très belle justaucorps du lac
du loch ness c'était absolument
spectacle magnifique dit qu'il a inventé
la libération totale de l'individu
c'est probablement là sa contribution
principale en effet nude est ce que vous
avez pris beaucoup de drogue à l'époque
de l'aidesep
je n'ai pas pris autant que qu'on a pu
le croire oui apparemment oui parce
qu'il a une bonne mine car il a
pratiquement 60 ans et qu'elle est
l'hôtel vous avez cassé le plus de
meubles est plus de chambres
au japon à titre d'exemple
qui a été découpée avec un épée de
samouraï à sabres est quelqu'un qui
essaie de rentrer à l'hôtel
à travers tokyo tout nu dans la rue
arabe et toumodi très polis par rapport
à tout ça on était des vilains garçons à
l'école
et notre gueule cathédrale c'est quelque
chose est ce que vous préférez comment
les morts
moi
c'était une forme d'hédonisme
cette façon de dire
c'est quoi la question si non à la
question suivante c'est une interview
vous êtes en france jimmy page donc on
va faire une interview fromage ou
dessert
est
[Musique]
ce que vous préférez des stones sous les
beatles
ça c'est une question intéressante parce
que débiteur
début je n'ai pas pris très au sérieux
il faisait des chansons comme please
mais c'est aussi un premier album ça m'a
beaucoup frappé ça va pas interpellé dix
ans mais quand ils ont commencé à faire
blue jam the world est prise au sérieux
et quand ils ont enregistré sa durée
quelques années seulement il est certain
que les beatles on développe se sont
développées de manière absolument
phénoménale c'est une force de la nature
en poste alors que les rolling stones
pour moi j'ai toujours adoré parce que
il venait en fait et même origine que
oui c'est à dire le blues brothers
malibu
comme ça est ce que vous préférez mick
jagger ou keith richards
je peux parler à qui je ne sais pas avec
d'accord est ce que vous préférez john
lennon et paul mccartney
probablement au john
john allen à coup sûr même alors est ce
que vous préférez que vos enfants se
droguent ou qu'ils écoutent britney
spears
écoutez vous êtes espère 6 à peu une
drogue surtout si on est un peu obsédé
par elle et les solutions dans l'espace
disque on le fait on le passe en boucle
mais mes enfants
et il adore enfin il se drogue à l'air à
dakar très bien est ce que vous préférez
quand pirates vos albums ou que plus
personne ne les écoute en vérité avec
led zeppelin
il y avait des cassettes à l'époque
c'était à cette différence les soirées
nain il y avait une partie été
échantillonnée qui arrivait chez
et puis il ya une période malheureuse de
l'image
j'ai essentiellement divorce et j'ai
quitté la maison et puis ya des gens qui
disent qu'ils se sont acoquinés avec mon
ex femme et à ce titre ils ont piqué en
fait tous ces échantillons
s'étaient tous les concerts qui a monté
à des années des années jusqu'à 1980 et
également des enregistrements de deux
répétitions de tout alors si vous pensez
à un viol musicale - une espèce de
drogue là vous avez un bel exemple
mais c'était malheureux et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il y avait
tellement de debon piratage y avait des
bandes maîtresses est ce que vous
préférez la première guerre en irak où
la deuxième alain plus fun j'ai pas de
préférence tranquille ou pour l'autre
est ce que vous préférez une bonne
bouffe ou une baisse moyenne wicked
liste de bouffe ou de baisse se serait
toujours un banquet pour moi d'accord
jimmy est ce que vous préférez votre
amour votre maîtresse
guitare
bonne réponse
merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu